i really want to start with a huge thank
you to hulu and imax for partnering up
to do this episode tonight uh because
it's the one time that fans could be in
a theater watching this on an imac
screen and to the audience that's here
uh thumbs up what did you guys think
yay
uh and i want to give you guys a huge
thank you for doing the q a um but
seriously thank you hulu i see you guys
over there seriously thank you and imax
thank you um david i want to start with
you and it's probably the most important
question up front
um how did you get your your first is
the mic on i think so yeah i was gonna
make oh it is okay i just wanted to test
it testing
yeah we're good
if i'm not mistaken your first writing
credit was on the golden girls that is
right yes how how
how was that that your first writing
credit was the golden girls
i'm old
that's kind of that's kind of my
takeaway too to be honest no but it's
actually really cool i'm like working
with a legend i was gonna say that you
didn't even know
no no you keep it closer okay thank you
i was i like so many people who
struggled again in the business i was
struggling to get in the business and
somebody uh submitted my scripts to that
show and they hired me
it i'm making it sound much easier than
it actually was i was gonna say it was
really difficult but i got hired with i
had a partner at the time and
we worked there for a couple years and
then we got fired so it's a real great
hollywood story
well i'm just curious for people that
don't realize when did you actually
start filming
this season the season or this episode
oh because it's very interesting this
episode was shot
at the be at the begin no we didn't do
one first we did three first
but when we shot one it was still in the
same year that we were doing three
but then we finished one at the end of
the season which was not quite a year
ago
so in between that time you know just to
piggyback on what um annie said is that
the kids
got taller they were my son
is taller than seth
and i don't know if you g those of you
who were watching from the very
beginning i used to carry both of them
on my back and i pride myself in like oh
i can carry them just let me carry them
that's what a mother does
omg
they are so big
you know so um it was
it was a challenge i'm not gonna lie we
do film out of order but i will say that
the two scenes uh that you guys saw
tonight my first scene with the isaac
and my scene that i'm arguing with ed
were my two
first scenes i had on my first day of
set wow
that was my first day wow didn't you
redo one of them i did redo one of the
scenes but it wasn't my first dance set
the first the first day on set you guys
watched tonight so we do film out of
order
but i will for my this episode in
general my two big scenes were
definitely filmed like my first day
but yes everything is out of order so i
understand what you're saying there were
still things from episode one that we
needed to film at the very end of
filming after quarantine so i'm curious
david if i'm not mistaken you started
filming this in 2019
and that sounds right i i don't remember
maybe september was it september no it
was um october
no was that
well we started fitting but it was after
seth's birthday so it was november
yes yeah yeah november that's right
because then we had the christmas party
yeah so you shot for i believe and i'm
guessing here but you shot for
four or five months that's about right
yeah and then covet happens right and
then you obviously come back and you
finish filming how much were the
episodes that you shot
pre-covered adjusted
like overall after because of the hiatus
of cobit like did you guys go in and
tweak scripts no actually that was the
that was the starting with seth on downs
that said he wants to do the same show
we would do whether it was covet or not
so we didn't we made no adjustments
uh these are exactly the this season of
episodes is exactly what we wrote with
the intent of shooting without covet the
only
the only thing that happened that was
that was sad was there was one episode
that we couldn't shoot right
uh for and i don't want to say why
um
we just couldn't do it
in
under the under the
safety protocols of kovid so
seth
wrote it as a novella which is going to
be released because he's got so much
free time
decided to write it right and it's an
amazing story and it's very sad that we
didn't get shoot but uh but otherwise
these episodes are they're exactly
what we would have done
if if covet hadn't happened the problem
was it that's why it took so long
because the coveted restrictions slows
things down you've got to be careful you
have to make sure no one's going to get
sick
it was double the time yeah truly i was
the first one back after
covet and you guys worked my butt to
death
and i loved it um
but it was scary it was scary because uh
everyone was massed up and they had this
looked like helmets but they were these
visors and no one could get near
people and so they came to toward you
and then they had to step away and you
thought oh my gosh we really have to
work in these conditions but we really
had to work in those conditions because
personally i love the heck out of the
orville and i was just
excited to
to get it done
i was gonna say
the scripts did get released way before
quarantine because the first two weeks
of quarantine i was so bored i memorized
all of my lines for the entire show
and by week three i was like okay so how
long is this gonna last like uh
i got everything done and now i just
have nothing to do and i
so
going back i was like yeah i've been
looking at this material the same lines
for probably i don't know three years
i'm really well prepared for this i
never looked at the script i know you
were really she was funny about that
only
the episode that you were doing you
would read the script right yeah because
i need to know what's going on but
why would i i you know someone asked me
this when we were doing the virtual
junket um a week or so ago
why would i put claire in my body in my
mind
when i'm sitting at home with graylin
and my dog chester and i just want to be
penny
because penny's pretty cool you can let
it go
and i just wanted to be penny i didn't
want the scripts in my head at all well
we have different actors that have
different processes
clearly okay for all three of you uh
there's a lot of fans who are watching
this right now for all for the three of
you what do you think
a fan of the oroville would be surprised
to learn about the actual making of the
show behind the scenes
[Music]
i think about i think about unk
because the days that i worked with ankh
was
you know a lot of things are cgi but unk
actually had that massive costume and
the guy under there was sweating so
massively the whole time and i just felt
really bad for him
and that that to me was the funniest
behind the scenes no i think you're
actually right about that i think that
kudos you would be surprised that
anyone who wears the prosthetic
they should get a standing ovation every
time they even just grace the screen
because the uh prep time for them
is
it hours before we come in and then they
have to sit in that chair and they have
to have it taken off before they go home
so i would i would say the would be
surprised about that i mean i'll i'll be
honest with you i did star trek before i
did deep space nine i did the next
generation was next generation i think i
did one of those anyway i had a nose
that they had to put on me and my call
time was 3 30 in the morning
for a 7 30 call
and when i finished that i vowed i would
never do a show where they have to put
anything on me so i give kudos to
and a 7 30 call by the way means
probably a wrap time around
at the earliest eight or eight thirty
nine ten and then they have to go and
take it off hours you can't just take it
off so that's an extra like two hours
so yeah you're right giving giving props
to them so you're trying to say that
making a tv show is not glamorous
no you should see our green room where
we hang out
it's really not glamorous
david i'm curious did you have an answer
for what might surprise people i think
people would be surprised how quiet
penny is
no
omg
okay
i am the loudest one she's actually i
don't care i i think that this season
that people would be shocked
at that
because of covet every those last all
the finishing the episodes happened like
like you were shooting a movie
uh so you had episode you would do a
scene from episode six
and then five minutes later you're doing
scene from episode four and then episode
10 and the the checkerboarding of the
schedule was mind-boggling and you would
be surprised because these actors give
you no clue they're in the moment of
each episode when you're shooting the
scene from that episode so i think that
that would be uh that would be the big
surprise i think other than penny losing
a lot of weight during the
thing
one of the things uh because this season
is airing on hulu and not fox the
episode that everyone watched tonight is
i think it was an hour and ten minutes i
know that you are not able to talk
spoilers for the rest of the season but
are the rest of the episodes of the
season like an hour and 10 minutes an
hour and 15 are they all longer than
what was that was uh there's one of the
reasons seth wanted to move into
streaming was he wanted sort of the
freedom to tell the story
uh
at whatever length they needed to be
told so there are some episodes there
close to an hour and a half um all the
episodes are longer than they would have
been on fox uh but
they all vary and it really just became
came out of uh this is the story we're
telling or these are the stories we're
telling we want to get them to to uh
the the natural conclusion which is
always the
always the intent that we've always had
on orbital but we were always limited
and you've got to cut this you've got to
cut that uh on hulu we didn't have to so
there's a variety of links i would like
to
give a spoiler they can fire me
um
i think that you guys are going to be
excited
because they are mini movies
but i think you're going to be
disappointed
that it really is just
too much
of a clever genius
to binge watch
uh you know i
i've seen
two of them and i could not watch them
back to back
and
it's good it's good that way because you
do need the time to digest
you need the time to
listen to
what is being presented i think it that
the the movies that you are about to see
are going to be movies that are going to
stir conversation
you're going to want to talk to each
other you can talk to me hit me up on
twitter because you know i can talk and
i will talk back to you
hit me up on instagram i'm not on
twitter really
but i i do think that
you will thoroughly enjoy it so if
that's a spoiler
sue me
but truly you're not going to be able to
binge watch i know a lot of people are
thinking oh i can't wait to get all of
them i think you really want to
cuddle up
or hurdle whatever it is you do and um
enjoy them as movies
i'm curious were there any scripts
that you had done or you guys had worked
on for the first two seasons that you
felt okay we can't do this in 50 in 48
minutes so we're not going to do this
episode like did you have any that you
were that happened to be saved for this
season because you had more time
no i think i mean
uh no they were all they were all
everything we develop we develop with
the sort of the consciousness of
uh what's come before so the show isn't
serialized
uh
we do like fans to feel like they
they're getting
uh
uh they're due that if you watch this
show there's going to be things
uh
in these episodes for people who pay
attention um so no they really there
wasn't um
i think we we had one script from season
two
but it was it was we we decided to hold
it over uh and i don't want to ruin
anything but it it it wasn't quite so
much for
we couldn't have done in season two but
we're doing it in season three and it
it's a
it's a killer episode wasn't that the
same for season one
i remember a script that was presented
to me that um we didn't get to do right
um
uh but in
season three you'll get a little taste
of what they were holding back for that
one
in season one i think so
yeah i know so i was playing that role
[Laughter]
i think so for people that are filming
right now do me a favor and don't post
what i'm about to ask because it's from
this episode um little you know spoiler
if you will um i'm curious for all three
of you this is like a personal question
do you think that isaac should have been
reinstated
or do you think he shouldn't have been
reinstated
that's a tough question i was so into my
character it's hard for me to even think
outside of it um
i mean yeah obvi i'm looking back and
the journey that you're gonna maybe see
charlie go on i feel like
i i have a different point of view
obviously i think he's very valuable to
the ship and
i i love isaac so
is is that as a character or or i mean
i i just was so into it yeah as a fan i
would definitely want to reinstate it
he's definitely needed on our ship in
multiple ways
as a fan i would watch this
for
lessons or things that would change my
life
and
we all have an isaac in our lives and i
think that people
should have second chances so as a fan i
would
i would be interested in saying how is
that second chance uh journeyed and um
what are the benefits and what are the
um
disadvantages of that because that's
what we do in life you know you have
somebody that drops out of your life you
know fourth season and a reason and
maybe they come back and maybe they
don't so um
but personally i i like giving second
chances i would like to see him come
back
david
i think we're in a time just being
serious now where where people are not
talking to each other and people are
doing uh bad things to each other and if
we don't find a way to find acceptance
which to me is one of the greatest
themes about this show this show is at
its core about acceptance that uh i
think
yes you have to you have to you have to
try to
uh accept
so yes absolutely
penny i'm curious what was your reaction
when you found out that you were going
to
that your character was going to have a
love affair
or fall in love with a robot
let's get past that green
blob first up
you know i said to seth um
actually i i said this i said
is there anybody that claire is
not going to have an affair with um i
mean
she's seen everyone in their nakedness
psychologically physically um
and the answer is
claire is open-minded
so
claire is open-minded but petty was
thinking what the
really
i mean really give me some get me avery
brooks up in here okay come on
but uh
hey i i am so
uh humbled that he has a lot he being
seth has allowed me to express myself in
those different ways i would be known as
a cougar being the oldest one in the
group and um
cougars have fun so hey
uh i know you can't do spoilers uh for
the upcoming nine episodes that people
have not seen however i am curious if
you have a favorite episode of the
upcoming nine that you cannot wait for
fans to see you could say episode four
or episode eight or you know what i mean
oh god i gotta do the happy dance oh
gosh there are so many oh i'm there's so
many there's not one there's the other
i like the i like the first and the last
episode a lot and then also
the
episode seven that david wrote i that
one's really complex and has a lot of
different story lines and i think it's
really really really interesting
uh it's it's all of them i mean they're
all really good i mean we're not gonna
sit here and yeah we're not gonna pick
favorites but my favorite
the one that i wrote is the one you
wrote
you know episode four i mean you know
it's the beginning of and what's that
about i'm not gonna say we're not right
we're like which one is that you'll see
in episode four
where this where this season's going the
levels that you know you you already see
it
in the first three and then in episode
four
and and it's up from there like i i
think that
uh we don't stop uh you know the the
episodes in
the big episodes in season two the the
kailan two-parter
would just be considered average
episodes in season three and
uh
the scope the movie making it's just
stunning and it
again
all the episodes are terrific there's
some stuff in episode four that i i'm
particularly proud of
is that a result of and obviously i'm
not sure what you can say but
going to who said everything i'm going
to say
going to hulu did that change how did
that how did going to hulu change the
writer's room in terms of possibly
writing things that now maybe you had a
little more money to do or you had more
vfx or did that factor in at all
it really just it really did just start
with seth and says saying
okay
this is the show we're doing and
we're going to do it right so he's a
he's an 800-pound gorilla and he has a
lot of support from hulu and the studio
to get it done and
we got it done it's pretty pretty
phenomenal season you know
growing up
your your parents would throw you in the
backyard and give you some sticks and
some stones and you'd make something out
of those sticks and stones you didn't
have to have a board game or anything
like that
well seth macfarlane is thrown into
a toy store and he is a big kid
and now
hulu
is the store owner
and they go he goes in there
to get a toy
and he can have all the toys available
and you guys will see
all the toys that he's been able to just
gather
and
it will be depicted in a major way uh
what did you think about the special
effects up there
nathan
this is the beginning uh being with hulu
is godsent
um i i've said this before
because you all know i was kind of
pissed when we went to hulu because it's
like oh we're bouncing up and down and
you know another but
i get it
and you will too i mean you were able to
see we would never have been able to
give you uh this magnitude on you know
any regular network television uh but
it gets as my pastor would say it gets
gooder and gooder
it truly does
uh david i know you're a huge uh star
trek fan
and i wanted to know and i know you're a
big fan of the original series but when
did you decide the next generation was
the best star trek
don't answer that you know it was deep
space nine i'm i'm totally i i'm not
answering that question right i'm joking
around because i don't think he's gonna
actually
fall for that no
[Laughter]
so you go with the first one being you
go with the original series i am i i i
love all star trek i'm a i'm just a die
hard fan i watch it all
it's uh it's not some some i like better
than others but all of them
have great episodes and all of them had
stinkers and that's that's television
and your best one is
[Laughter]
uh annie i'm curious so did you how did
you get this role and what has it been
like for you because you obviously got
cast in 2019 and you're a big part of
this series now and you are then waiting
three years for it to come out
i mean yeah the pandemic i mean
obviously no one could have
predicted
um so that would have happened with
really any show rather it was this or
something else like i said the outfits
was a little bit of a throw off for me
um
but yeah getting the role i mean look as
an actor you go out on a million
auditions you get told no a million
times and then you get told yes it just
so happened i've been out for the
casting director sheila jaffe a bunch of
times and
um i really loved this character it was
something really interesting and new
that i've never done before and that's
kind of what i searched for just as an
actor i want to show as much versatile
acting ability that i can and i was like
i want to be thrown into this completely
new
universe of a different um just world
that i've never dived into so i thought
it was really interesting auditioned had
a meeting
and booked it do you guys end up with a
lot of deleted scenes on the show um are
there a lot of things that have been
shot that fans have still never seen
[Music]
i've never seen anything on the floor
because i remember all the scenes that
i've that i've done i don't know like
clippings yeah never really never really
full scenes little clips out of scenes
bits of dialogue
uh there was a there was uh a scene
which i think we showed of
of borders and clyde and golf outfits i
don't know i feel like that showed up
somewhere uh it didn't you don't
remember seeing it
you saw it online right yeah so like
that was i think the only thing we've
all a couple of scenes like that but
very very little it's usually little
snippets of things do you guys find in
the writing in the writers room that
certain characters are
do you get the vibe that certain
characters are easy to write for or are
there is it sort of certain people have
that voice on certain characters what is
it like actually you know in the writing
process well you have talented actors
and so you you they
you you write something with a character
in mind
and then the the actor uh brings uh
brings so much brings it to life that
then you start writing to the things
that you've enjoyed watching those
actors do and that happens a lot on the
show where
you know you watch you and that and you
you watch an actor do something and it's
like oh we want more of that let's let's
change this let's add that uh so it's
it's a
it starts with
defining the character on the page but
then working and collaborating with that
actor so that the person lives so that
it's not just some some two-dimensional
character on a page but that it's you
feel like they're real people isn't it
also scoring um because i i i always
find that when we're at a table read and
i'm listening to it that um seth has
this ability to hear voices you know
being a voice over actor and i think
that he has
meticulously uh cast
everyone so that the sound of the voice
and the vernacular i think that's true
that it there's a musicality um if if
you would just close your eyes and
listen to the orville uh you know and
that's why the music is so great too
everything is a comp is complementary so
um i think that's a conscious choice
because i one
one day that we were casting some we
like i'm doing that um
they were casting the macklins
and um in the table read
i said
oh
are the mocklands the black people
i just asked it because you know i'll
just ask anything and seth looked at me
he says
oh no penny i said well then how why is
it that all these people are black and
they're the macklins
he said
the voice they came in and they had a
certain voice a certain base in the
voice
and that's what i'm that's when i'm
casting i'm casting the sincerity and
the gift of the voice so i think again
it's a musicality of all of our voices
together which is um i i think it's a
gift
i'm just curious do we have that ball to
give to the fans
or to the fans the audience what is it
it's the imax ball which allows people
to ask questions which can be recorded
it's actually it's a it's a square it's
yeah but it's the box the imax
so um uh can you do someone want to ask
a question and is that on is it
styrofoam
oh there's a do you want to go down
there or just hand
that is so cool i want one does it yeah
it works okay cool guys uh thanks for
coming because uh really appreciate you
to see this on the big screen
i'm sure all of you can answer this uh
it's kind of tricky territory but i'll
ask david specifically too
you know obviously seth loves star trek
you love star trek you know
and obviously you guys talked about now
with hulu you're able to do longer
storytelling you're able to basically
make movies and more action
because you see it going that way
has seth ever talked about maybe we'll
do the orville the motion picture with
this theatrically bring it back to tv
maybe there are stories that we can tell
on a grander scale you know exploring
farther out in the universe do you think
we'll ever see a theatrical kind of
entertainment with the show
i mean i think you'll be you're going to
see some theatrical entertainment this
season but
um i think
uh he's up in all of it and that's about
that's about whether the fans show up
yeah i mean that yeah i i don't think he
would close off that possibility right
now
though
right this stuff you're going to see
absolutely is is on the level of any
yeah one of our episodes that had more
special effects in it than right force
awakens because you watch this and
you're like you got to see it on the big
screen you know so it's like hell yeah
that that is i guess
one of the downsides but the upside is
you can watch it 10 times in a week
exactly into the theater i think i i
personally cannot wait to see the
episode that's an hour and a half um do
you want to pass it up there
you can throw it by the way
yeah yeah that is nice it's fantastic i
love this i don't want to break an imax
we do this all the time
as a psychologist and on the heels of
mental health month just first off i
really appreciate the complexity and
nuance that you all approached
trauma grief suicide with and one of the
things i've loved since we've talked
about star trek
and the orville in the past and penny i
think you were talking about really
being able to process and think through
some of the future episodes are really
those moral and ethical dilemmas my wife
commented like was this good enough
moral and ethical dilemma for you in
this episode i'm curious in moving
forward
from the writing room producing acting
are there any of these challenges and
nuances that were difficult for you
personally to be able to put forward
absolutely yeah
the one that you saw
um
actually came on the heels
in between shooting it
a huge tragedy in my family
and um
it
was difficult there was
a scene that you saw tonight
um that we weren't going to do and then
seth said oh penny just do it just i'm
only going to do one take and it's gonna
be a wanner i'll just have the camera
move around
and i said okay seth he said just give
me what you got
and i said okay i'll just i'll do my
thing
50 takes later
you know
that's the scene when claire breaks down
and um
the tragedy that my family had gone
through
it was just so raw and just there i
could have done it a thousand times i
didn't wanna but um it was emotionally
exhausting and usually
i'm never exhausted emotionally because
i just do this thing it's i love it it's
my passion but that particular scene was
very difficult for me
i mean i'm not going to say a personal
experience but i will say just as an
actor in general just working on really
any set having to do any emotional scene
there are things that are happening in
your life and it doesn't matter what it
is you have to still go that day and
perform that scene so if it is something
emotional and you're having to break
down and something just happened in your
life then
you know you have to kind of bring that
and let it shine and that's honestly i
mean
you you see it you see that pain or you
see that hurt on on screen and i think
it really shows whether or not it's from
something that's happening in your life
or
on camera um i'm sorry that happened i i
i'm not gonna attest to something that
happened to me on this show but just in
general as an actor you have to
kind of do that even regardless of
what's happening in your personal life
and it is challenging
and again
i was interested in watching you in this
you're you're so angry
and you don't strike me as someone who's
an angry person
is there somebody you're like in your
mind modeling or is it or what or are
you just connecting to actual anger oh
that's a good question i mean my dad
jesus
um
no i
[Music]
i don't i don't know that was kind of a
tough thing to do was kind of have that
find some sort of person in there that
has like a vulnerable sense and that has
a human
to her and also be very
angry at somebody which i'm not used to
but that's again
as an actor i tried i don't i i i'm not
an actor that has maybe certain personal
experiences that i like think about but
i just try to really put myself in the
situation
and think about the fact that you know
in my mind this k-lon
species killed my best friend if i
thought of anybody
outside of the k-lon or outside of this
world that killed my
best friend i would like i i could see
how she would hate them so that's kind
of where i draw it i just think about it
um in like another in another world
that's a really good question
but can i answer it as an actor and as a
person who sure teaches the stuff
um anger
is just
love it's hard too
it's it's it's the same passion and the
emotion
that you give for love so you don't have
to experience anger to play anger
uh you have to know about passion and
what something means um
just like you were saying you know you
you take the subject at hand and um
your question of it's not that i wanted
to recreate what was there um i want to
be clear on that because you know those
are called private moments and things
like that and the whole acting world um
it's because
it had happened and in the acting world
you actually use
what you have
and that was forever present i could
have been doing a love scene but that
didn't take away from the fact
of what had happened
so i if i was doing a love scene
you would have seen some kind of passion
in that and then you'd ask when i go i
had a tragedy in my family it would be
the same it's accepting and allowing
what's going on in your personal life
and using it kind of in terms with the
scene that you're doing that's what i do
accept and allow what's going on in your
personal life use it in the scene and
see what comes out of it with the
context of what you're doing in the
scene
i mean look if i got you know if i was
called onto a set and i was a heroin
addict i'm not gonna go and be like oh i
need to really like
really really really see how this feels
today you know what i mean so you have
to still be able to draw from things
that aren't necessarily that would ever
happen
i would love to play that but i'm i'm
just saying you don't need to experience
the things that you're portraying
there's other like you said anger is
love or it's hate there's other emotions
and things that can be portrayed from
different emotions you have in your
personal life
um so i have some good news and i have
some bad news
and uh and i'm just gonna throw it out
there the good news no the bad news is
we need to stop recording the q a
because of uh
the theater like we we have to end the q
a however the good news um the the
talented people to my left um have
offered to um uh meet people and take
pictures and other things outside the
theater um so if
if that's okay
we'll stop the q a so people can maybe
take some pictures i talked so much and
stuff um is this okay
we're actors we talk we talk
we could have had more questions sorry
for our long answer no i mean i i think
here's the thing like there's a choice
like we could either and just being
honest we we can keep on doing questions
but but then there weren't there won't
be any pictures or anything and i think
that a lot of people would rather take a
picture and
that kind of thing let's split the
difference let's take one last question
if someone
is to ask the question we need to we
need the imax ball does someone have uh
a question that i know there's some kids
in the audience everyone's like no we
want pictures
right over here
right
oh there we go
i love all the pins on your jacket job
thank you
um hi oh that's loud okay so
um
when when filming uh
like post like brand new coven
guidelines but ignoring that what's one
of the most difficult things you as like
a cast have had to deal with
um in regards to like the longevity of
each episode especially since you're
doing 10 of these
what's the most difficult thing you guys
have had to like experience within that
process
filming it all out of order and just
trying to remember like there's days
that we have
just being on the bridge
just being in the you know the space
shuttle and we'll do like five different
episodes that was kind of difficult to
know like where you were coming from
where you're going and those kind of
things but
i i would say that's that's was my
biggest thing
this season the biggest thing was
working around
jessica's pregnancy oh yes that was
difficult too but and when she came back
me being you know very maternal
wanting to make sure she was safe
and um we weren't
overworking her which we did because we
had to because we waited for her but i
think that was the biggest thing because
with a cast like the orville
we don't like each other
we freaking
love each other and we get all in each
other's business
and so we're protective of each other so
you know we'll we're looking out for
each other i know i'm looking out for
the kids i go like don't use that
language in front of those boys don't do
that and we're all looking out for each
other you know like oh that let her do
it again you know so
we talk a lot as you know because listen
to us now
but the orville uh reality show coming
soon yeah i think we're overprotective
and that would be that's the hardest
thing that we have to just overcome and
you know that we get to work but we are
about to work
um just real quick uh i'm going to have
everyone i'm going to have our talented
guests go outside first but before they
do i really want to say a sincere thank
you to all of you for coming out tonight
thank you thank you for doing this thank
you to imax
and uh thank you to our brilliant camera
team and everyone for making this happen
tonight um thank you for real
you